turkey is still battling natural
disasters
its south was on fire for weeks
now the north is under water
a two day downpour has taken hold of the
black sea region a month after floats
and landslides killed six people in the
area
almost a dozen people have now been
forced from their homes
we couldn't understand what was
happening it came in a rush took
everything and went away now we don't
have any belongings or anything
flood waters swept away vehicles and
record many homes and businesses
search and rescue crews were immediately
sent to help the stranded
but some of them were hampered by roads
and bridges that had already collapsed
we are fighting another natural disaster
we are in sunope which has lost its
connecting roads in five locations we
have also received bad news from
castimono and barton
we are trying intensely to open the
roads
the worst hit province is castamono
where several people were killed
a woman in nearby barton is also
reported missing
rescue helicopters now try to succeed
where land vehicles have failed
but the meteorologists have warned the
region to brace for more rainfall
right now nature's wrath is felt all
over turkey and more so by those who
have lost everything rasul serdar
al-jazeera istanbul